What do you want from me what is this about
What is this about
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my full video
explaining thenew version of lady loki on the loki series
this character who's a combination of a couple
different characters we call her lady loki but
she's a little bit different from the comic book
version of that so i'll explain all those easter
eggs there's some really cool easter eggs and big
ramifications for marvel phase 4 in the multiverse
with what she's doing in her plan so we'll break
it all down if you're new to my channel i'll
be doing videos for all the marvel disney plus
series episodes be sure to subscribe to get those
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your predictions for what they do with
her after the events of the loki series careful
for spoilers if you have not seen all the loki
episodes so far up to this point but at the end
of loki episode 2 our loki finally comes face to
face with the variant who mobius brought him on
initially to take down the showrunner said that
the blade runner movie helped inspire some of the
series in that mobius is kind of like the deckard
character the hard-boiled detective hunting down
replicants in these alternate loki variants so
when this loki variant unfurls her hood and is
revealed as a female loki most people naturally
assumed it was the show's version of lady loki
from marvel comics but there was this big twist
in the credits the credits for most of the several
different languages that they dubbed the show
into still only referred to her as the variant
but the latin american credits listed her
as sylvie and if you re-watch the episode
with the fine-tooth comb and really look for the
hard-to-find easter eggs you might have spotted
her actual full name appeared in the episode so
our loki at least if he was paying attention saw
it on the page already so he already knows who
she is exactly when loki is looking at the files
right here after mobius sits him down initially to
look at the incident reports on lady loki her full
name is listed as sylvie laufeydottir canonizing
her as the daughter of le faye making her a loki
but the reason why her name is sylvie is because
instead of lafay having a son in an alternate
timeline that this sylvie came from laufey had
a daughter left her for dead just like our loki
then a version of odin in that reality found
her took her in for the same reason that he took
in regular loki as a way to ensure the peace
between the frost giants and asgard was kept
also to kind of take pity on this dying baby that
was left for dead laufey seems like a deadbeat dad
in every reality and then instead of naming her
loki he just named her sylvie but the name sylvie
is a reference to sylvie lushton in the comics the
second version of marvel's enchantress amora is
the true enchantress they've never actually done
her in the movies of the tv shows before maybe
because dc has their enchantress that they've
done in the movies and the tv shows i'm not
sure if there's some sort of marvel dc copyright
issue that's going on there maybe we'll actually
see marvel's true enchantress appear somewhere
in the future the sylvie lushton enchantress
was created by lady loki though she was a normal
human girl living in little asgard in broxton usa
which is kind of like their version of new asgard
at the time and lady loki just created her as a
sort of fun mischievous experiment for no better
reason than to just cause some trouble on earth
but this version of sylvie eventually did join the
young avengers team and took amora's identity as
the enchantress amore herself got super pissed
about it they had it out on the loki's series
this sylvie laufeydottir uses enchantment she has
blonde hair and she speaks with an american accent
loki kind of calls her magic a cheap trick but
that's mostly them just trading barbs like both
versions of loki have huge egos and they're both
stalling for time so they both won't shut up
loki makes a joke about this later like now i
understand how thor felt why he was always so
annoyed with me but this version of sylvie on the
tv show is not meant to be the enchantress she's
still a loki she's just an amalgam of a bunch of
different aspects from different marvel characters
and different versions of loki for instance the
costume she's wearing particularly the broken
horns in the loki armor fine asgardian leather
fine corinthian leather looks just like i cole's
costume from the comics that was the new version
of loki that came after lady loki in the comics
he also had a storyline that crossed over with
kid loki who was also a separate version of the
character the ico version of loki was more like
the next form that the original regular loki took
when he was reincarnated and the reason why you're
seeing him depicted here is both a man and a woman
is because he was kind of like a non-binary
version of the character so he would flip
back and forth to male and female so sylvie
here on the tv show is a lady loki because
obviously she looks female but if you want to
get technical she is not the lady loki from the
comics because her backstory is very different
the real version of lady loki was more like the
regular loki who just stole sif's body around a
major apocalyptic marvel event called siege he did
wind up going back to his normal mail form before
he became the ico version of the character though
but every time the original loki would go from
being regular male loki to lady loki to eichel
was during major apocalypse events so sylvie
laufeydottir loki on the tv show's actions
in going through apocalypse events to hide is a
reference to that the reason why they're calling
her sylvie laufeydottir instead of just calling
her loki or calling her lady loki is i think to
make her feel as different as possible from our
loki make her feel like a distinct character
she even tells him don't call me that when he
tries to call her loki because she doesn't want
to identify herself as a loki even though she
was born as a loki so to speak the writers the
producers want her to feel very different they'll
also be selling a lot of merch for all these
alternate loki's so they want her to feel like
a very different toy like not just our loki in a
woman's body that's why they had that big mobius
speech earlier in the episode saying that loki
variants from alternate timelines could look very
different and have very different powers to set up
the twist of how sylvie could still be a loki but
look nothing like our tom hiddleston loki or have
a british accent even the funny thing about that
though is that sofia dimartino does actually have
a british accent in real life it's just that she's
playing the character with an american accent so
just to be clear she's not the enchantress she
is still a loki because she is laufey's daughter
it's just that when odin adopted her instead
of naming her loki he named her sylvie and the
reason why she set all these time reset bombs
off blowing apart the sacred timeline is part
of her grand plan is because it's all part of her
larger plot to destroy the tva in the timekeepers
and prevent them from erasing alternate timelines
that they deem to be non-sacred because she came
from a timeline that they erased they're heavily
implying that she's basically the remnant of this
dead reality that they got rid of because they
thought it was bad mobius and the other tva agents
had all those jokes in the previous episodes about
her being the quote-unquote superior loki way more
dangerous than our loki just trying to offend our
main loki as much as possible and get him to work
that much harder to capture her and prove himself
the superior loki because his ego is so big
all loki's egos are so big they kind of joke about
that when loki and sylvie are trading barbs back
and forth through the episode please if anyone's
anyone you're another me if you watched the
invincible tv show recently it's a great animated
tv series they had a joke about that too where you
have a couple duplicates arguing about who's the
duplicate and who's the original but the idea on
the tv show is that the time keepers on the series
are kind of bad now sinister maybe the tva itself
started off with noble intent but mobius and loki
had that long conversation earlier in the episode
about how all good things eventually get ruined
they were talking about jet skis in the 90s but
the conversation was meant to be a metaphor for
the tva itself a dark knight type of speech you
die a hero or live long enough to see yourself
become the villain and that's kind of what's
happened to the tva here the time keepers
themselves are immortal so unless you find a
way to kill them they'll never die at least in the
comics i know we're all expecting some big twists
with the timekeepers too like do they even exist
are there any time keepers or is that a lie too
there's definitely some big lies being spun
inside the tva so you had this idea that even
though sylvie laufeydottir might have gone on to
become one of the greatest loki's in existence
potentially when her timeline was created through
a nexus event the tva determined that it was a
mistake and it wasn't part of their grand plan
for the sacred timeline so they went in to erase
her reality but she escaped and then started on
her quest to take down the timekeepers in the tva
itself blow apart the sacred timeline so that the
timekeepers couldn't selectively choose who had
the right to exist that's why she kind of laughs
when r loki tries to offer her the team up when he
explains his plan to replace the timekeepers like
join me i'm looking for a lieutenant i'm going to
replace them she says she doesn't want to replace
them because that would just be more of the same
handing the fate of trillions to a single person
and she wants the whole paradigm torn down like
no one should get to decide who lives and who
dies it's like the thanos argument like nobody
should have the right to choose for the entire
universe everyone in existence who gets to live
and who dies and as you see are loki sitting down
for a chat with her in this new apocalypse event
in future episodes the show runner said that just
like in the blade runner movie r loki will start
to learn more about himself as he learns about the
lives of sylvie and these other loki variants that
they encounter there are a bunch more other loki's
that we'll meet too like president loki we haven't
met him yet and then there's possibly a version
of kid loki that's supposed to show up on the
series and that'll help our loki become a more
compassionate person who's more thoughtful about
his actions less selfish and is just part of his
redemption arc becoming a hero that's also what
sylvie means when she tells loki this isn't about
you she's not just trying to take down the tva and
destroy the sacred timeline for herself for her
own selfish desire for revenge she's doing it
for all the other people potentially that will be
killed in future alternate timelines that would be
created through potential nexus events that the
tva would then move in to destroy like it's not
about you it's about everybody so through the rest
of the episodes loki will slowly start becoming
less egocentric about this but at this moment at
the end of episode two when he's chasing after her
sylvie laufeydottir into the portal tom hiddleston
just said that it's his curiosity as a loki
getting the better of him like right now in this
moment he doesn't care about capturing her so much
he just wants to learn more about her and what
her plan is so the whole idea here is that sylvie
laufeydottir is not the villain that moebius and
the rest of the tva has made her out to be she's
actually trying to help everybody that the time
keepers would potentially or theoretically get rid
of should they deem them non-sacred but at least
at this point in the story our loki hasn't figured
that out yet and that's going to make itself clear
probably over the next couple of episodes they're
making the reveals pretty quickly but i think
that's because tom hiddleston said that they take
a dramatic left turn in the story during episodes
four and five there are six episodes total so this
whole lady loki sylvie laufeydottir reveal is just
the tip of the iceberg obviously they have the big
reveal of what's really going on inside the tva
what's really going on with the timekeepers and
then what happens with the future of the marvel
multiverse in the mcu so for a lot of you asking
if sylvie actually created the marvel multiverse
when she blew apart the sacred timeline here
because now there are many other alternate branch
timelines that function like fully alternate
realities the multiverse did exist before the
events of the loki series as the ancient one
tells dr strange in that first doctor strange
movie but as i mentioned in my previous video
the way that they describe the multiverse in each
movie is just dependent upon what the director
wants to do with the story what the writers want
to do with it so in the first doctor strange
movie when they're talking about the multiverse
they're referencing all the different dimensions
of the multiverse which is a little bit different
from the traditional multiverse you think of
in the comics the marvel what if tv series is a
good example of that it's a big multiverse series
they're going to be assembling a multiverse
version of the avengers team with a bunch of
alternate versions of characters from different
realities all those episodes are going to start
in august i'll be doing full episode videos for
that but what silly was doing here wasn't so much
to set up that series as it is to sort of lead
into the events of doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness like post all your doctor strange
memes him watching the end of episode two like
what the hell is going on over there this whole
idea that the loki series and what they just did
blowing apart the sacred timeline creating all
this madness so to speak as they sort of set up
in that big explainer in episode one is really
where the chaos and the multiverse the madness
comes from even though what scarlet witch is
doing is also a big part of that it's just
that after watching the loki episodes it seems
like it's going to have a much more legit effect
on doctor strange two's plot than one division
was kevin feige also revealed that the loki
series would have ripple effects affecting all the
future marvel movies as well so i think that sort
of goes hand in hand with the events of spider-man
3 no way home with all the spider-verse elements
that we've been talking about and as we go along
and we see more easter eggs and foreshadowing for
other future marvel movies i'll point those out
as well i will do a new video on all the kang
the conquer easter eggs sometime soon too we'll
just continue to see those in all the episodes
so there's going to be a lot of big stuff like you
re-watch the episodes a couple times you'll always
find more easter eggs but i believe the idea is
that after the loki series they will still keep
this alternate sylvie laufeydottir loki around in
the multiverse she will still continue to exist
they're not going to kill her off at the end of
the series so she's kind of like an ag of the
hardness type of character little bad little good
but just really interesting with what they could
do with her in the future so let me know what do
you want them to do with the sylvie laufeydottir
character in future marvel projects if they want
to bring her back there will be a loki season 2 so
i assume she would at least come back for that
what'll happen though is i have a couple other
videos that i'm working on there's supposed to
be some big trailers in the black widow movie is
coming out really soon too so i will do some more
black widow videos when i have a chance to see the
film i'll name a new giveaway winner when i post
my next big marvel video everyone click here for
my loki episode 3 trailer video and click here
for my full loki episode 2 video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!